and open up the special subcommittee on
parenting coordinators
slg's and today we will be working on
the parenting coordinator part of
this
we have a bill House Bill 1263
I think needs a little bit of work
before it's supposed to be exec tomorrow
and I
would like us to look and see if if we
think that we can kind of make something
work about it since we did think that
this was important enough of a topic to
have a subcommittee on it I feel like we
to complete
this for this year if we can if we can
can't then that's okay but I'd like to
one yes
rreg thank you madam chairwoman um so
one of the things that I'm noticing and
I think we've heard come up from our
Advocates too is that we don't really
have um one of the you know one of the
stickiest parts we have when we're
looking at um helping parents out is is
the domestic violence portion and so
having some training um in domestic
violence would be a big one we don't
have any kind of a a carve out to help
with that I think that's probably one of
those areas that we have the most
confusion around kind of what that means
and what that's looking at so I'd like
to see something with that another
complication that I've heard uh you know
some people talk about is where is this
training going to come from and who's
going to
kind of mitigate that or keep an eye on
that so just a couple thoughts that I
have in my notes from that
okay thank you those are good points I
did look into what a few of the other
states are doing and some of the other
states the court actually does the
training themselves um I know in New
Jersey they do and they kind of Branch
it off in two different ways where you
could be a parenting coordinator just
for General cases or if you also want to
do domestic violence cases then you have
to complete I think it's in let me see
what the number of hours were for the
training program and I know
[Music]
um I did look around and several other
states
do um have this with DV and I did want
to say I know that there was some
concern brought up with using this with
with DV cases in general but there are
several other states that are doing it
and it
doesn't and it's the amount of time that
they've been doing it for I would think
that if it was creating a big problem
they would have repealed it by now um so
I'm happy to add in the training for it
I do I know that there was concern about
perhaps like oh exclude DV from there
which my personal opinion and I'd like
to hear what the others think is that i'
I'd like to avoid doing that because I
think if somebody's
already a Survivor and you know has
already been through a lot they should
be able to have the choice we shouldn't
be you know they've already been kind of
controlled enough to speak this is both
parties have to agree to it so if they
don't want to agree to it they don't
have to do it um and I know particularly
I've heard concerns
um about litigation abuse and the amount
of money that has been spent trying to
fight these things and
sometimes they're at a last resort like
can we agree to something because if not
I'm ready to drop everything because I
just I can't afford an attorney every
more and I know I know the Coalition
does the best that they can and some
attorneys will volunteer for some of the
stuff but the reality of the situation
is of course the attorneys have to feed
their families too and they can't take
on every case for free that they would
like so sometimes when these cases go on
and
on I mean there's there's not much that
they can do so I feel like it should be
an option available I don't want to tie
the hands that you can't have this tool
but I'd like to hear your thoughts if
you'd be okay with adding in some
training but not completely excluding
and saying that
if there's domestic violence you can't
do
this yep I don't know how freely uh you
want us to talk or how formal um so the
that reminded me when you were talking
about that the one of the other things
that we're um hearing about is of course
there's these are in high conflict cases
and we're talking about Aon agreement
which normally in high conflict that
they're not um in agreement on pretty
much anything which isn't always the
case in DV cases I mean in DV cases
sometimes they'll agree to it because
they think they can yeah I mean a lot of
times they think they're right there's
not a lot of insight into whether or not
there is DV which is why it's important
to have somebody else come in and say
this is this is not healthy uh
relationship um
experiences so I don't know you know is
this a wording that you've seen in other
states that that's working on I mean or
the upon agreement in the high conflict
or this is just something that we
decided to
try so there are a few states that are
using a pawn agreement there are some
states that are just ordering it and it
doesn't necessarily have to be a pawn
agreement okay but I was trying to make
it I think at least to start I think it
would be nice if parties agree upon it
and they're doing so willfully and free
freely and I think some of the other
states that are ordering it also have
much more subsidies available that
they're able to just fully pay for it um
and I have
mixed feelings about potentially
ordering something that you're going to
make somebody pay for I just don't I
don't know that it's right to say oh you
have to do this and then you have to pay
for it I think you know it's kind of a
different step if you're going to say do
you want to do this do you want to pay
for this and the both parties can agree
and go into it so it's and I also don't
want it to be an effort in futility
right if if the parties are like nope
there's absolutely no way we're going to
agree on anything we don't want to do
this what's the point right but if the
parties are like you know what we've
gone through all of this neither one of
us are getting what we want um we'd like
to just sit down and see if perhaps we
can't agree to something and I think you
know having this background of more you
know psychology social worker maybe they
can get the parties to agree on
something that makes
sense yeah I I I think the um I think
not being an attorney is helpful not NE
doesn't don't necessarily have to be an
attorney um I think any training uh and
DV would would be helpful I mean I don't
know what hourly training they have now
is it two three hours is it 24 hours is
it 40 hours I mean the minimum the
better
um I know I know uh the court said that
um these coordinators are very helpful
uh when the parents agree to them um if
we man if we mandate it um then the
court needs the money to pay for it um
so I I agree that it ought to be first
it ought to be um both
parties um
agreeing um and I mean keep uh keep a
log of that so that another year we
could take a look at it and see if it'
be beneficial to uh have the card pay
for
it
yeah let me take a minute to just look
through and just see I did we did get
um trying to why can't I her name is
blanking me a committee researcher
regarding parenting coordinators and
other I was going to just kind quickly
go through and see the number of
hours
um do you guys Dyer yeah it was
Christina Dyer so I think we have that
minutes
all right we're going to come back in
okay go
ahead so we've already had to have the
parents have to agree or whatever and
they have that time to take that away
like that whether or not they agree on
the parent yeah seven days coordinator
but then when you go on the second page
to line
four that they they'll file a report so
the Partington coordinators have this
report but it has to be agreed on by
each party before they turn it in in a
DV case or other cases that's never NE
both parties are never going to agree so
unless it comes out unless it comes out
amicable to both people which I can't
ever imagine happening in a high
conflict so I think once I mean if we
have a parenting coordinator once it's
been agreed upon that the parent
parenting coordinator of who that's
going to be it only makes sense that
whatever the parenting coordinator that
was agreed upon has their report that
should go into the judge period like
that's why why would we make the parties
agree to that so some feedback that I
got from several of the family law
attorneys that was that
basically if I'm going to agree for my
client to go to this and speak freely I
would only do that if the report has to
be agreed upon by both parties otherwise
I'm going with my client and my client's
not going to be speaking freely there
because I don't want a report to come
out that's going to potentially make my
client look bad and so if you want the
parties to actually go in in good faith
to decide on
something that was a suggestion that I
got from several of them what do I mean
this otherwise they were like there's no
way
because yeah it'll be the same thing as
like a gal in the sense that the gal
just gets to say whatever they want to
say and the parties don't get to agree
on it or not and so he's like people
will just either never agree to use this
or they're going to go in with their
attorneys and it'll be a waste of
time so the parties even if they don't
don't agree to the
report uh they would still be
responsible to pay even though there's
nothing coming
forward um absent the agreement by both
parties the parent Corner shall not
testify nor produce
records correct so but each party would
be paying for half of it so you would
think that the parties aren't going to
be going into this in the sense of oh
yeah I'm going to go in here and just
waste time because they both would have
a financial interest in not wasting the
time um I would say that it does say in
here the the one caveat in here is that
the parenting coordinator May recommend
that one party pay all or more than half
based on a part on a party's failure to
work in good faith with the parenting
coordinator or the other party or for
other good cause and that is very
explicitly says may recommend because
it's up to the judge to ultimately
decide what the judge wants to do but
that is the one kind of thing that's in
here if a party does go into it in bad
faith and they're truly not trying to to
make it work that the other person's not
going to get stuck with half a bill for
nothing um and so that was kind of the
piece that was put in there to try and
make
it you know we're going to make sure
that we're not just wasting time or
money in this because if you are doing
that then you're going to be stuck with
the one wasting the money so the the um
the reason for the parenting coordinator
is for the parent correct correct so the
judge does it help the judge to know
who's cooperating and who
isn't I mean that that that would be
another um you know I mean I think that
the judge would know if the parenting
coordinator was recommending that this
party is not acting in good faith that's
kind of the only caveat is that this
parent is not acting in good faith so
I'm recommending that the other person
pay like that's kind of The Only
Exception there I do know that there was
one other thing pointed out during the
test testimony that somebody had had
asked
um if a party objects to the appointment
the court shall appoint a different
person or confirm the appointment within
seven days and so
um that one they just wanted to get rid
of or confirm the appointment um just so
that it's it is agreed upon and that
they're not going to appoint somebody if
somebody is objecting so that was one
other thing that's on line
um yeah in terms of the filing of the
report that was like a sticking point
that I did get back from several of of
the family law attorneys so I don't know
so what what would
um what would be the case if or is it
even possible for the uh for the judge
to get the
report and he can't weigh in on it well
I guess that would be uh well the that
the judge would get the report and it
wouldn't and it
uh and if the parties don't
doc I mean somebody's got to I mean
people are paying for this
thing
um right but you're the same concept of
you're going before a mediator and if
you're not agreeing in mediation then
nothing goes before the judge there
I think it's just another tool to have
available and it's the same thing in
mediation if the parties don't agree in
mediation then nothing goes before the
judge yeah but I'm thinking in
conflicts
um this is the suck and bite at the
Apple no way you're going to get to you
know no way first going to get him to
agree to use somebody secondly get them
to
agree to the
report I mean the report's going to show
one of them in a bad
light little or a lot so the point isn't
really supposed to be to be showing a
party in the bad light or not it's kind
of just to get the parties to agree on
what might work out right like we've got
a judge here that doesn't know what the
parents schedules are they don't know
that Susie has gymnastics uh on Mondays
and that Michael has hockey on Thursdays
and that you know dad works until this
time and mom works until that time the
parties all know that the parties all
know who typically takes each child to
what not and what schedule would
actually work best for their family
right rather than a judge blindly just
ordering and saying well on Mondays and
Tuesdays the kids go on with Mom
Wednesdays and Thursday the kids go with
Dad and every other weekend we swap back
and forth between the parents I I really
think that if the parties got to have
some weigh in and give some you know hey
this would work best for us based on our
family so I'm not I think it is a tool
I think if if we saw like how it was
working and that there was you know more
to be changed with it at some point if
we thought we wanted to have you know a
different path
where potentially it it's court ordered
and the parties aren't agreeing I think
that's something different to look into
but for now I think it's nice to start
it off with it all being elective
and the part's agreeing or not if they
go for an if they go and they sit down
for an hour and they spend $150 and
neither of them agree you know what it's
less than the cost that they're paying
for that they're each paying an attorney
fees you know for an hour of attorney
fees so if they go and they sit and it's
just not working then they can end it so
currently they were assigned by the
judge what's assigned by the judge uh
the parenting
coordinator uh currently they say
currently no the the parties have to
agree currently they're really not using
parenting coordinators I guess there's
one in nsha that kind of does it
privately but it's not okay so it's not
like through the court and there's no
court ordering around it okay all right
because my understanding the testimony
was that it was very successful so that
was through not used enough yeah so that
was through the the one private that was
through the one private place that's
kind of doing it in nsha but I don't
think that it's really very widespread
and that was more of a the parties did
it on their own but the judge hadn't you
know been involved with the ordering of
it okay
uh and and then and seven you got the uh
immunity statement that's going to be
another
uh I I I absolutely agree with it uh but
that's going to be uh I mean that's what
we're hearing in these Family Court
matters is judges immunity attorneys
immunity uh I mean I don't think's
immunity I don't think without any sort
of immunity in here that you're going to
get anybody to ever take the J and I
mean I think unless the Omission causing
the injury was willful or wanton I mean
I think it's you know if you're doing
something that's kind of outside of the
scope of your duties or you're willfully
doing something then you're liable for
it but okay I think if you've got two
parties that just aren't agreeing
um are we going to accuse the parenting
coordinator that it's their fault you
know we're bringing rasing a
professional to get involved in kind of
an already high conflict situation and I
don't think they want to go through
litigation with somebody either you know
okay uh should we also have in here the
data what we're looking for in data that
they will keep records
on you know so that a year from now well
actually uh in
26 we we could look at the data to
see um you know 40% of the time the
parents agreed to both the coordinator
and the um and the
report okay
up hello again hi good morning thank you
for coming um so regarding the
collection of the data would that be
something that would be the court would
easily be able to do in terms of
collecting the data um for if you know
how often parties were agreeing to use a
parenting coordinator and how often that
the court was getting a
report um the short answer is it's it's
not a part of our current case software
which as you know is is very frustrating
for legislators because it is um it
tracks case numbers party names dates
but but not really any kind of
information um so it would have to be
something that we'd have to to send out
a directive basically to every Court to
have the clerks specifically noting it
reporting it back um to the AOC and then
collecting it there um and then giving
it to the legislature which is something
we we can do it's just a certain number
of Staff hours that are not currently
committed to that
purpose now would that be a big effort
or do you think that that would be
something that could easily be absorbed
into the current workload of
staff I think generally we did have hire
a new uh data and statistics person and
we're trying to kind of get better data
and statistics for parties that are
interested including the legislature but
others are interested as well um and and
typically there's the the front-end
collection um which is a certain number
of uh Staffing hours but then we' want
them audited by someone who's a data
expert after to make sure that it is not
bad data I mean the biggest challenge we
face is inconsistent application of our
data requests so we we may train all the
different clerks and say we want this
data but um they have different ideas of
what's collectible what's success or
they neglect to do it because there's no
business purpose to doing it and they
forget so we'd have a person kind of go
back over it and and check that the the
quality of the data is good so I don't
want to represent that it's not some man
hours I can certainly check with our
budget folks if we get a a fiscal
request on that or it goes to finance
and and those numbers are needed but
there would be a certain number of
involved I don't think it would NE
necessitate hiring new staff it would
just be letting you know how many hours
that takes
up so so uh I mean just I I I understand
giving this a a try uh I mean I'm I'm
willing to
um uh to agree to this under that you
know under that belief um but I mean I I
I would just be looking
for how many how many more cases um
agreed to a parenting coordinator both
um agreeing to the coordinator within
seven days and agreeing to the report
and those that didn't agree with the
report and that would I mean
they other data would be good but not
necessary you know as to why there
wasn't an agreement
or um you know
just I'd like to know that parenting
coordinators have increased
substantially in in those cases and uh
that they you know I'd be interested to
see the percentage of parties that agree
with the
report and to start to me that would be
I mean if it's 30% I'm happy yeah so I
guess for those two data points you know
for for first how many agree to to using
the coordinator and then second for how
many agreed to their report would that
be something that you guys
could do on your own by Court rule or
would that be something that we would
need to put in here legislatively as a
mandate I think it's generally helpful
for a data collection to have it in in
legislative language we we can always do
things on our side and we do you know we
spend a lot of time getting um different
types of information that we see are
repeatedly of Interest either to private
citizens the media or the legislature we
we often do do that ourselves but I
think it's unhelpful because um as as
director Reay of the FBI says many
people want the FBI to do more but very
few want it to do less um so we have a
lot of conversations with folks that
they want more or more data or more
services from the courts and it's
helpful to quantify it so that even
though this may not require hiring a new
staff or if 15 bills pass a legislature
this term in the aggregate that might
require a certain number of staff to be
added to the court yeah the only reason
that I'm asking more so is that once we
put this in here then you guys are going
to be kind of having to collect that
forever until it's changed versus if you
agreed to do it on your own and we were
like okay we've collected the data for
two years we're happy with the numbers
we don't need the numbers anymore then
you guys aren't having to give us
numbers that we don't care about anymore
waiting for somebody to agree to take it
off the table I guess that's my that's a
good point I think you know a
conversation about things that the
legislature finds helpful can be just as
effective as getting it in mandatory
language and we can just as easily
present the aggregate of all those
requests when we do our annual budget
um and say you know here are all the
things we've been asked to do and and
this is how much it'll cost so I take
your point I think either way you know
In fairness we can we can have a
conversation about it or it's something
that you certainly can put in
legislative language okay and then
relative to training for domestic
violence is there any training available
through the court for mediators or or
attorneys that the that the court um
either puts on or is is put on by
another organization but that the court
knows of that these parenting
coordinators could
potentially take part in that we could
kind of put that in there if you know of
one do you know approximately how many
hours it is I don't I do know that the
guardian Ed Lim board um generally when
they're certifying Guardians Ed lium
they they either take someone with an
Associate Degree with a th000 hours of
relevant experience someone with a
bachelor's degree with 600 hours of
experience or someone with an advanced
degree with 200 hours of experience and
they have some training programs that
they recommend um because we don't we
don't typically
um administrator the training oursel um
so they may have a little bit more
information on some of the options
because certainly that's something that
they deal with a
lot okay thank you let me I'll
I'll uh so when uh when the judges pick
in
gal's and it's a domestic violence uh
issue will they look for somebody with
that experience I think if you I I think
so and and you'd look for someone
experience experienced if it's in
training or experienced a lot of
experiences a gal um you know the more
challenging the case the more you want
someone who's really demonstrated a lot
of proficiency as a GAO and if it's an
easier case where it's just helpful to
have a g between two parties then then
maybe you would take someone who's a
little bit less experienced but for
something like that I think you would
want someone very experienced okay okay
so was your thought process there that
maybe we don't have to mandate the
training that the court could look for
somebody with the TR like
I yeah I'm I'm not sure if a judge may
want a parenting coordinator uh with a
with I don't know if they have domestic
violence training uh or experience even
because they're not attorneys they're
psychologists or what have you um so I
don't know if adding the training is is
good I mean we would have to determine
what training's out there and what are
we requiring them
to
Point yeah because I would think like a
gal the court I mean I would think like
based on some of this already like if
um if you're
already um holding a New Hampshire
license in your area of practice such as
you know say psychology or social work
that you likely through that would
have some sort of DV training like I
would think if you're a
family therapist you would have DV
training but I mean can I say for sure
that they
do well no but I think to your point is
a judge going to look to the ones that
they know are experienced in that area
so line
16 participate in 24-hour training I'm
not not sure if any of these trainings
include that they
may I mean I guess you know we could put
into we could put into part of this part
D that we would also say
um and domestic
work all right so if we add into line 18
the domestic violence part into that
training and then we remove from line 26
or confirm the
appointment
um thank you attorney krian much
appreciated um and then the court is
able to get us the data on their own
um would you guys
be supportive of this or do you think
that there's anything else that we need
to look into changing what's your
comfortable which one were you looking
at um 26 yeah 26 so if a party objects
to the appointment the court shall
appoint a different person or confirm
the appointment within seven days so it
was asked during the hearing to the just
to delete the or confirm the appointment
that way they're not confirming somebody
that the parties have objected to okay
okay y yes R Greg thank you so I you
know what I think that that's good I'm
I'm really hung up on that section six
now because I think about when I think
about what we're doing in the high
conflict cases so just trying to figure
out because our schedules are weird and
that's not high conflict the kind that
I'm thinking of like the high conflict
where we have to go to another party and
say you know either help mitigate this
or what are the complicating factors
that are getting this high conflict um
and I do have experience in a number of
high conflict
cases the biggest thing is is is there's
generally some it's not necessarily
domestic violence abuse right but there
is some sort of abuse whether it be
through you know a power trip of
somebody wanting to just have control
over everything um but there is you know
and it could be both parties you know
kind of having that same control so I'm
looking at this particular paragraph and
thinking even though we've helped them
you know and we have somebody that maybe
has the the DV and you know all this
other stuff once we get to this that
doesn't matter because this I see this
more as a weapon now to like okay let's
see if we can push this through and then
when it gets this point I can say no I I
mean I understand the want for a
disclaimer but that's just not the type
you know of help that we want to get
because it's it's just so complicated
and this is this would be more
weaponized also if we're letting them
use you know um from the mediation and
arbitration fund which is super helpful
in a lot of cases but say there's
somebody that can get that that can get
the arbitration
fund what happens when they decide okay
I don't want to use that like I'm going
to see because I don't have to pay for
this I can get this arbitration fund and
now I can say no I mean I see this more
as like a a way out for a party that's
not necessarily working in the best
interest of everyone or certainly the
children that's my and and full
disclosure I mean I'm on I'm a
co-sponsor of this bill um but the more
I look at this and the more I think
about it I just think about how many
cases that we really need this
process so I'm happy to discuss changing
it but in full disclosure every attorney
I spoke to said that they either they
would likely recommend that their
clients did not participate in this at
all or if they did they would go with
their client and it would be mute so I'm
not sure like that I I just don't know
if it would ever be agreed upon to be
used if we changed that part that's my
concern true and that's frustrating by
the way I mean that's that's a
frustrating thing that you know if we're
trying to get the parents and by the way
if they can then afford attorneys
they're probably not using the
arbitration fund exactly but
um and the arbitration fun it I doubt
that it's actually going to end up being
used it was just put in there as an
option if the court wants to use it if
the court sees like hey these
parties both of them are prosay I think
they could really benefit from this we
just we want to use it then they then
they could consider using it but it's
not any type of a mandate it says that
the court May um and to be fair like I
did ask a dozen attorneys about this and
they all said the same thing so I
couldn't find one that said oh yeah I'd
be fine with that they were all like
nope no way okay well that's where the
data will be super important then to see
like how many people are I would also be
interested in how many people are going
through this process and then saying no
we're not going to have the report sent
in because that's a that's a big deal
yeah and if that I mean if that comes
out and happens then we we can repeal it
if it's just being used as a weapon then
that's certainly not helpful to anybody
for them to go through the whole process
and then it's all for nothing you know
yeah so so in testimony my my perception
was that these parenting coordinators
were very helpful even though there were
few uh and it just made sense to me uh
so that's why I'm willing to risk agree
in with this because we don't know you
know we could we could think that'll add
more conflict I don't know um I I mean
it's another level where the conflicted
party would have to go through um which
sometimes I think when you put stuff in
their face they're like yeah I'm being a
little unreasonable right um so yeah I'd
be I'd be willing to do this you know in
you know after a year um get the data to
see where it's all going it may not you
know you know it may not go where we're
thinking it's going and and and I know
this par coordinator is an
advantage you know I want to I want to
try it you know how do you feel are you
comfortable with that even with the
report thing in there and we can come
back to it if if we see that it's
causing a problem ba based on that I
mean I feel better about that I
definitely just would be
interested you know in that in that data
on that but I overall I think this needs
to happen I just want to make sure that
we're we're doing it you know it's one
of those things you you try to prevent
that um that all that stuff that you're
going to learn in hindsight um so just
trying to think about every Avenue but
overall I think the one thing that we
have heard over and over is the
importance of you know something like
the gal system that really I I feel like
is kind of you know a little bit of
water on a a grease fire um but I think
the parenting coordinator opening it up
and having the DV training and doing all
this especially if we can work with the
courts with the data and stuff I mean
I'm I'm going to have the same impulse I
did you know and and wellth thought out
impulse though that I I think this is
important I would agree to that so yeah
so so when is the uh coordinator
paid after it delivers a report once the
parties
confirm um once the part's confirmed so
the parties would agree and may be
paying the
coordinator once the report was done
however they still would have to decide
whether they want the report they accept
the report typically these types of
people would have to be paid like
Upfront for their services like when you
go to the doctor's office and you pay
your co-pay or if you have no insurance
you pay the full cost of the of the
visit UPF front um yeah so it's usually
upfront so that they're not I chasing
the parties around to to get the to get
the money I have the same issue that uh
representative Craig had with the
arbitration fund mediation fund you know
it can be
used um I qualify for that I don't have
to accept the report I'm
golden you know I and that's why I think
it's it's important that all this
language is enabling and it does say May
the court May appoint a GU you know a a
parenting coordinator um the court may
use
so I think these things are all really
very discretional and if there was I
would think these would be like the for
the for the fund to be used that would
probably be more like a very special
case
scenario um and not like a typical thing
I know that they have a limited
arbitration fund anyway so I
don't know that it would be used very
often but there may be circumstances
where you know a judge is like I I
actually think these parties could come
together and maybe agree on something
they just need the right person to help
them
um
yeah yeah and I would think that the
uh the parenting coordinator's time is
more prior to the report than after the
report correct right
okay so are there any other changes that
you guys would like to see in here or
are you okay with those two in your are
okay y okay all right I will send this
to OS now and then um regard regarding
the rest of the committee where do we
the G portion of things do we think that
that's something that we want to keep
kind of looking into do we think we want
to see maybe where this goes and then
reassess the g g portion in a year after
we've seen like maybe this parenting
coordinator can kind of play a bigger
role what are your
thoughts uh did did we have a g bill we
don't have a g like specific Bill
okay okay uh yeah because I know uh the
G's are currently enabled they can
currently be used they're just it seems
like they're not being used very much
due
to kind of a lack of agreement with them
and there's no funding for them so the
parties have to pay for them and the
parties mostly aren't wanting to use
them although I think we weren't able to
necessarily get specific data regarding
how many were using them but it's from
asking this the judges kind of to try
and get that anecdotal data it was not
they were not very used right
now but um and I think kind of some of
the feedback we got from that was that a
lot of the G's right now were more
lawyer based and not necessarily coming
from this you know psychology social
background work where they may be able
to kind of help the parties to agree
more rather than discuss
like you know the legal aspect you know
figure out the legal aspect of things um
do you think do you think attorney for a
child
specific may be helpful with the G
issues so is that another bill that
there was another bill that went they
already uh it already passed yeah okay
so do we want to see where the that bill
and this bill go and then maybe look at
it we recommend that you know it
potentially be looked at after we've
seen how both of these go for a little
bit yeah okay okay all right yes Qui I I
think one of the biggest things that you
know we noticed even with the the gal is
that you know and I wish it's that whole
data thing right it's like the Achilles
heel I wish we knew how many families
would take advantage of it that it would
help like you know when we sat in on the
court cases we had a couple families
that wanted it but they couldn't afford
it you know and and knowing like how
many people were missing out especially
once we go into a budget year again you
know we're not in that kind of budget
year and so then that then we start have
to talking about next term and who's you
know going to be here and who's not uh
to look at you know funding that again I
think that was a great disservice that
unfortunately happened within our state
when we didn't no longer funded that
program but besides that I think this
and then that having the attorney um for
Miners and stuff I think that these two
are steps in the right direction I think
the next big step would be getting that
funded again and I just I that's not
going to happen this year so okay anyway
thank
you is there anything you wanted to add
you not to put you on the spot I totally
am putting you on the spot I this may be
the last subcommittee that we have on
this if we're kind of agreeing to and I
and I don't want them to end so I'm
prolonging the the meeting um no thank
you very much uh there's there are a few
things I hear more consistently from
judges then it would be great to have a
gal fund again um um they rarely want to
weigh in on policy they rarely want to
say anything but I think they have the
experience that you observed which is
people come in and they would love to
have them and they just can't pay for
them and there's that it's it's it's
unfortunate that there are so many
people I know it's it's frustrating that
we're we're not trkking it but you
observed it all the judges observe it um
I really appreciate your attention to
that issue because I think it it is
something that would really make a
difference okay so then that that could
be something that we put in our report
to to make sure that we're looking into
for next year when we're going to
actually have a budget year that might
be a good time to kind of look into that
meantime if there was a
way to ask even just a few of the judges
like how to kind of how often would you
how often would this be helpful like
especially the judges that you're
hearing hey it would be great to have
this funded um if there's like a
specific Court location that maybe
doesn't doesn't have a lot of judges and
one judge would be happy to just keep a
tally sheet hey I would have used it in
these cases like just getting some data
on it I think would really be helpful
because that obviously was a fund that
was quite a bit of money so in order to
get that money I think people are going
to
want some data rather than just a few
judges said this would be great you know
I think that would go that would go much
further and certainly that's not a
mandate that's just a recommendation
that if the court wanted to give that
data that may be helpful with with
getting that funded again again that's a
that's a helpful observation and since
we do have this new data person let me
see if we can do like a sampling like
maybe we go to our most populous courts
and as opposed to having every Court uh
and see if there's something that we can
do that instead of it's everyone it's a
sampling measure maybe um so let me look
into that than thank you for that that
would be very helpful just uh um I I
know there's not clear data on this but
somehow just keeping in the back of your
mind How would any of these
initiatives help in setting dockets you
know uh budgeting time for the courts um
you know I'm thinking this may help um
how much I don't know um so just you
know it doesn't have to
be on paper you know a report on paper
just you know whether judge Ashley or
judge king will come before us and
saying you know we believe we saved x
amount of hours um so thank you by using
um parenting coordinators by using
parenting coordinators
y my hope would be that if we have
something
more uh universally able to be used like
something like the gal or where we're
helping provide that actually helps in
costs on our courts you know that you
know that that can help not only with
the costs in the courts but also um
expediency and um making sure that we're
utilizing uh the courts to the best of
the ability and not just prolonging
things for a long time that would be
that would be my Hope on that that we'd
probably save in one area by bringing up
another perfect does anybody have
anything they wanted to
add thank you all for all of your help
and work it's much appreciated all right
then I will close the hearing and um I
will put in a draft of the things that
we spoke about into language and then we
can vote on that as a full committee
you